the scene you're about to watch is
perhaps one of the most important and
influential sequences in the history of
cinema okay this could use some
explanation this is a scene from Mary
Poppins a 1964 classic directed by
Robert Stevenson it's a film often
regarded as Walt Disney's crowning
live-action achievement being the only
Disney film to ever be nominated for
Best Picture in his lifetime but there's
something else that's often overlooked
about this film it was also that year's
winner for Best Visual Effects now for
film featuring a magical flying nanny
you might not find that to be surprising
at all but it's this overlooked
achievement that helped Mary Poppins
changed the course of film history
forever
like all forms of art films have always
relied heavily on bringing our
imaginations to life as films evolved
this posed a great challenge for early
filmmakers imagination had no boundaries
but film did at the time at least early
on simple camera tricks were used to
make the impossible look possible George
Murray is one of the first pioneers in
visual effects used a technique known as
double exposure mattes to achieve this
feat over a hundred years ago a man with
multiple heads he did it by putting a
glass panel in front of the camera and
painting black marks over specific
sections to block the light he would
then rewind the film and set up an
opposite mat to fill in these blanks
individually then voila despite its many
limitations if the double exposure mats
were used for many years until something
a little more familiar to us arrived on
the scene this is the blue screen
developed by a Lawrence Butler and it
looks and works similar to the green
screen we use today with the arrival of
color films Butler realized he could put
a subject in front of a specific color
then remove that exact color to isolate
a subject from its background the
isolated subjects would then be placed
on top of a pre-shot background known as
a plate to create a single seamless
image this is a start of what we now
commonly know as chroma key this method
was first used in 1940 for the film
Thief of Bagdad but it also came with
many issues the color blue was selected
mainly because it was a color farthest
from the skin tone but this meant that
any costumes or props with a blue hue
would simply blend in and disappear with
the background
and if the lighting wasn't perfect it
would end in these blue halos that you
see around the actors so when Walt
Disney acquired the live-action film
rights to Mary Poppins they wanted to
tape the opportunity to push the
technology even further especially for
one particular sequence where
live-action footage merges with Disney's
classic hand-drawn animations for over
16 minutes but instead of hiring a
special effects artist for the job
Disney instead asked for help from the
engineer and inventor Petrov Vlahos
so what did Vlahos do to begin well he
got rid of the blue screen fully aware
of its limitations he sought for another
color to replace it his answer yellow
well more specifically the yellow hue
from sodium gas the same light you see
in street lights Laos knew that sodium
gas produces light at a very exact
wavelength 589 nanometers in comparison
the blue used in blue screen ranges from
435 to 500 nanometers by shrinking the
range of wavelengths Vlahos knew he
could greatly improve the accuracy when
isolating a subject this already solved
many problems from its predecessor for
one things didn't have to be lit as
perfectly and there were no limitations
on the colors of props or costumes for
example Dick Van Dyke could wear this
blue bowtie and socks because sodium gas
emits a very specific hue of yellow he
was also able to wear a blazer with the
yellow stripes to achieve the effect the
actors would stand in front of a white
screen lit by a yellow hue from sodium
vapor lights hence its name the sodium
vapor process unlike the blue screen
which required tampering with actual
film strips to achieve the effect vocês
method was completely within the camera
he did this by creating a unique prism
that was designed to isolate the 589
nanometers hue from the rest of the
colors this simplified the process of
creating a more act
Matt the silhouette image that's vital
to the process the result was astounding
even by today's standards it's difficult
to find a fault isolating a more
specific range of wavelength allowed for
a crisper image practically eliminating
the halo effect of the blue screens you
need to look no further than this veil
that Julie Andrews is wearing to see how
impressive this technology really was up
until then isolating a material as fine
as a veil was deemed impossible until
voix house's new invention and it was
this technological marvel that earned
Vlahos the oscar for visual effects
there was an issue however despite
multiple attempts to replicate it vas
can only create just one working prison
which meant there was only one sodium
vapor camera in the entire world after
showing its capabilities in Mary Poppins
other studios and filmmakers fought to
use it and this single technique would
go on to be used for almost 40 years in
notable films like Alfred Hitchcock's
Birds and the original Pete's dragon
after the success of Mary Poppins Vlahos
would go on to further develop and
improve the chromakey process the result
was what eventually became the basis of
the modern green screen for this reason
Vlahos is often regarded as the man who
made the modern blockbuster possible
without Disney's gamble and Vlahos ease
ingenuity and innovation we might have
never seen Mary Poppins on the silver
screen
not to mention films like Star Wars or
Jurassic Park with Mary Poppins louse
not only gifted generations of people
with one of the most beloved classics of
our time but a legacy that can make all
of our wildest imaginations come true
you
you